[موسيقى]
في الآونة الأخيرة
، تم إجبار العديد من الشركات على
دراسة قيمة ريادة الأعمال
، وقد أثر الوباء العالمي على الكثيرين
ولكن للخروج من الأزمة تأتي الفرصة
لأنه عندما يكون لديك فكرة كبيرة ،
فإنك تتكيف وتبتكر
وهذا ما اضطر محمود أثم
إلى القيام به  افعل
فكرتي الكبيرة هي إنشاء علامة تجارية محلية
صحية يمكن أن تصبح عالمية قبل ست سنوات ، فقد
أنشأ شركة وجبات خفيفة صحية في دبي ،
وهذا هو المكان الذي يحدث فيه السحر حيث
نصنع جميع طعامنا من الصفر.
الوجبات الخفيفة الصحية التي لا
تحتوي على أي شيء سيئ
تساعد الناس على عيش نمط حياة أفضل
والاعتدال في تناولهم
للسكر ، بدأ صغيرًا مع مجموعة من
المنتجات مثل
الوجبات الخفيفة للطاقة والبروتين ، هذا هو
قلب العمل وهذا ما
munchbox
يشتهر بالكرات التي يتم لفها ويسقطون
في
سرير من مسحوق جوز الهند قبل أن ينتقل
إلى
المحطة التالية نمت مؤسسته
بسرعة وأصبح ناجحًا للغاية
عالميًا مع الصادرات إلى
السوق المربح
في الولايات المتحدة قبل كوفيت ، كان لدينا
موزع رياضي في الولايات المتحدة
إلى 7-11 هناك ولكن
لسوء الحظ
لم يستطع ذلك عندما حدث الطمع ،
كان الأمر صعبًا حقًا
لأننا نوفر مئات محطات الوقود
التي
نوفرها  إلى الفنادق التي نوفرها
لشركات الشركات
، انتقلت المبيعات من x أصبحت صفرًا
بين عشية وضحاها
في مواجهة الشدائد ، وعندما
تفكر كثيرًا ، يمكنك الحصول على إبداع ،
أخذ آدم نشاطه التجاري عبر الإنترنت
وطور مجموعة جديدة من المنتجات التي
تستهدف
اتجاهات غذائية جديدة مثل keto و palio
نحن  أطلقنا 45 منتجًا جديدًا
قمنا بصنعه مجموعة من
المتطلبات الغذائية المختلفة في مربعات مختلفة ،
أحدهما عبارة عن وجبات خفيفة من الكيتو والآخر يحتوي على
وجبات خفيفة منخفضة السعرات الحرارية ووجبات خفيفة غنية
بالبروتين ، وقد بدأنا في بيع
تلك المنتجات عبر الإنترنت
، وقد حققنا نجاحًا كبيرًا مسبقًا ، فقد تم
تغطية خمسة بالمائة بعد ذلك ثلاثين  في المائة
أه
هو المبيعات عبر الإنترنت ولا ينمو
أي شخص للراحة على أمجاده ،
بل إنه
يغير نموذج أعماله أكثر.  لن
نركز فقط على الوجبات الخفيفة الصحية
ولكن توسيع النطاق الذي سيوفر فيه
صندوق الطعام مجموعة من الأطعمة المغذية ،
لن نكون شركة وجبات خفيفة فقط ،
بل سنكون شركة أغذية صحية
يمكن للناس الوثوق بها ،
لذلك عندما ترى  المنتج على الرف
مهما كانت
الحبوب الزيتية التي تثق بها تلك العلامة التجارية